It gives me great pleasure to
introduce two fabulous graduate
students from the University
of Washington.
I've gotten to know them
a little bit over time.
Dom spent two internships
over here, and
we haven't been able to
get him out already.
This will be a great talk on
information visualization.
And they work with Jeff Hera
over there who for
some of you might know Jeff
has been responsible for
a lot of different
innovations and
graphics including prefews and
flare, the D3,
and now, the Vegas series
that we'll be talking about.
They're going to be graduating
in about a year, year and
a half, so
they'll be on the market.
So this is actually
pretty nice to know.
And as I said before for those
that were in here, they're gonna
be sticking around for
a little while this afternoon so
we can setup some
one on one talks.
Send an email and
I can schedule that, or
just come up and
talk to me afterwards, okay?
So, thanks very much and
take it away.
>> Cool.
Thank you.
So, before we begin our talk,
I would like to advertise
about all our interview study
on exploratory data analysis.
So if you regularly perform
especially data analysis in your
work, I want you
contemplate your research.
We looking for people to
participate in our studies.
And this is our URL
bitly/UW-eda-study and
I think our ask you to
forward the email to people. Yeah.
Cool.
So, today, we are excited
to present about Vega-Lite,
A Grammar of
Interactive Graphics.
In this talk, we will show
the design of the language and
show how you can use it for
your daily work.
And since we have time,
please do feel free to
ask questions any time.
To begin with, so we already
have so many tools for
grading visualization and
one of the most flexible class
of tools for our languages for
composing visualizations.
The example of tools in this
category include D3, Vega,
NTG Plot, and the language
underlying tools like Tableau.
Since that,
there are already many tools,
why do we need another language?
So and just how we walked
through first walked
through what we like
about these languages and
see how real life goes
beyond these languages.
To the part an expensive
range of graphics,
many popularly finished tools
adopt the ADF on The Grammar of
Graphics by Lee Wilkinson.
The idea is just how
grammar teach us
how to compose words into
sentences in English grammar for
graphics provide primitive
building blocks for
composing an extensive
range of charts.
For vision coding,
these building blocks include
data that we want to visualize,
transform light filter
aggregation and binning.
Graphical marks, such as bar,
point, area, length,
the including mapping between
data and property of this marks.
And scales are function that map
data values from the abstract
domains to visual values
like pixels or colors.
And finally, guides such as
access allegiance that visualize
the scale functions.
With these building
blocks true for
customize with efficient
designs such as between radar
offer fine-grained control for
composing interactive graphics.
This kind of tool can
be very expressive, but
they require verbose and
some technical expertise.
For example, creating a bar
chart in D3 would require at
least a few dozen
lines of code and
some level of expertise
in JavaScript.
In contrast, they support rapid
exploration, both in terms of
exporting data and exporting
different visualization design
to such as ggplot2 and Tableau
allow more concise sketching,
but emitting low level details
such as scale and guides.
These two then infer
sensible defaults for
these omitted properties, and
allow customization by letting
user override default values.
These tool with classification
are flexible for
rapid exporting and access.
However, they can limited for
specifying interactions.
In assigning Vega-Lite,
our mission is to facilitate
exploratory data analysis by
providing an expressive yet
concise language to specify
interactive multi-view graphics.
Inspired by this previous
language, we're going to provide
a concise language to express
a bot range of visual encodings.
In addition, Vega-Lite goes
beyond this additional grammar
interface by providing
operators for
composing multi-view graphics.
We also sell building blocks for
composing interactions
using selections.
With Vega-Lite, all these
building blocks are available in
a single, unified language.
So next part, Dan will first
show you the design of Vega-Lite
and after showing the design,
I will basically show you how
to you can use Vega-Lite
as a programming tool and,
I will let Dan show
you the design.
>> Okay, thanks Sam.
So, when you are creating
visualizations, what we have to
do is we have to create a visual
representation of abstract data.
And this helps us to
amplify cognition.
The main task of
the visualization designer is
then to define how abstract
data should be encoded visually
without having to worry
about little of the details.
So to scales, or axes,
or how to draw these.
Take for example, this weather
data, with information
about the precipitation, and
wind temperature in Seattle.
This data doesn't have an
inherent visual representation.
Here I create the table
to show you the data,
but inherently this data doesn't
have a visual representation.
So if the analysts decides
that they want to look at
a particular aspect,
they can for
example create a strip
lot of the temperature.
And this shows us what they
temperature range is in Seattle.
In a bigger light a single
view like this one here is
specified by encoding
properties of as
explained earlier in the based
on the grammar of graphics.
So Strip plot is a visualization
where we encode the value as
the exposition of the tick mark.
Temperature here is variable
that shows a magnitude So now,
our syntax, what we need to do
is we need to specify the data
source, and then, the mark that
should represent the data.
And most importantly,
we have to define the mapping
of data values to visual
properties of that mark.
And in our language,
we express all of this in
a declarative JS range.
And JSON is very easy to
process with common programming
languages and it's native to the
web which is why we picked it.
Behind the scenes,
the Vega-Lite compiler
reasons about the visualization
and results ambiguity about low
level details such as
the scales and axes.
And it does so with reasonable
defaults as you can see here.
And emitting these details
allows us to have a more concise
specification.
These defaults in Vega-Lite
are designed to follow best
practices in
visualization design.
But if the user wants to
customize it, they can override.
So any of these properties
that you see here
you can override, for example.
So going back to the strip plot,
it shows us the spread
of the temperature in Seattle,
which ranges
from a couple negative degrees
to around 36 degrees Celsius.
However, it doesn't show as how
many days have a particular
temperature.
So we don't know whether
it's one or 10 or
more days that have this
15 degrees Celsius.
And in order to see that, we
could create a Histogram, which
shows the number of records that
fall into particular ranges.
In other words, a histogram is a
visualization of a distribution.
So now the question's, how do
we create this in Vega-Lite.
Well, in the grammar
of graphics,
a histogram is a bar chart with
the bars the underlying mark.
The exposition is determined
by a binned field and
the aggregated count maps
to the length of the bars.
So let's go back to the strip
lot that we had earlier and
transition to the histogram.
First, we discretize
the temperature data.
Then we encode the count, so
an aggregate, as the y
position of the tick mark.
Notice it already looks
kind of like the histogram.
All we have to do is change
the mark type to bar, and
now we have a histogram.
And yeah, so this is how
you create a histogram for
quantitative data in Vega-Lite.
You can change the data to a bit
different data settings, and
it will still work the same way.
To make sense of histograms,
Vega-Lite uses a binning
algorithm, which discretizes
the quantitive data in human
understandable intervals.
Beyond that, Vega-Lite also
determines sensible defaults
to parametrize the binning.
In the histogram,
we bin the x-axis,
which is the positional channel.
Instead of showing
an ordinal access,
Vega-Lite actually creates
a quantitative axis as a guide.
We know from the visualization
data chart dating back
to Cleveland and
McGill that the position is
also highly discriminable.
So we can use a large number of
bins to show the temperature.
If you instead use
a non-positional channel,
such as color, opacity, or
shape, then Vega-Lite generates
a legend with range labels.
So rather than
the axis as the guide.
And it also uses
fewer bins because
color is less discriminable.
We have a harder time telling
apart different colors.
It's much easier for us to tell
apart different positions.
So having a grammar allows us to
reason about the specification,
and optimize the visual output.
With the grammar,
we can incrementally customize
the chart as I've shown you.
Another incremental
customization is to add
an encoding to
an existing visualization.
So for instance,
we can encode the dominant
weather type using the color.
And then we get histogram that
shows us what the dominant
weather this is for days with
the particular temperature.
By default,
Vega-Lite colors that
don't resonate with my feelings
are about these weather types.
So we can customize the scale,
domain and range so that this
that are drizzlers more gray,
just hard feel with drizzle.
So when we edit the color
encoding, Vega-Lite
automatically stacked the bars
instead of layering them.
This is another example of
these sensible defaults.
Because of the stacking,
the overall shape of
the histogram is preserved.
And this is what you can
see here on the right.
In this case,
multiple things are interacting.
To do this kind of reasoning,
the Vega-Lite compiler took into
account the channel, which was
color, the mark type, which was
bar, and a layout transform,
which is the stacking.
And these three components
interacted in a non-trivial way
to create a stacked chart which
is more expressive than the bar
chart with overlap.
Just to show you that this
overlap happens if I change this
to a line you can see that
these bars are in fact
on top of each other.
And so snow would be completely
hidden behind these other bars.
The stacked histogram more
accurately shows us the data
than a e-version would.
It's still hard to compare
particular bars here.
For example,
these two gray boxes here,
because they don't share
a common baseline.
So instead, we could take this
histogram with color, instead of
using color, we could lay out
all of these bars in space.
And so now we create one
histogram for each weather type.
And it makes easier to
compare the boxes here.
And this is the first
example of Layered and
Multi-view composition
in Vega-Lite.
Vega-Lite has the grammar
to compose views and makes
them fit to new opportunities.
And in our grammar, we've
developed four basic operators.
The first one you've
already seen, the faceting,
which we just used to lay
out the histograms in space.
And what it does is it
partitions the data by an
ordinal field and then creates a
view for each of the partitions.
A facet is the only operator
where each view gets
a subset of the data.
In the other operators,
each subview gets access
to the full data.
One of those other ones
is the layer and operator
where we can stack multiple
views on top of each other.
With the concatenation, we can
combine arbitrary views and
create complex
multi-view displaced.
And repeat is a concise and data
driven way to concatenate views.
And as a running example
to go into details for
this, for operators,
we'll use this histogram here
that shows the monthly
precipitation in Seattle.
As might not see this beautiful
place but we try to scare
tourists by claiming its raining
all the time which is of course
not true unless you're in
November and December.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which we are right now.
Anyway, let's talk
about the square chart.
So in this chart,
the x-axis encodes the date
which is grouped by month, and
here we use this field time unit
which automatically puts all
the days with the same
month into one bin.
The length of the bar
encodes the mean or
average precipitation of all the
days that fall into the month.
So with the layer operator,
we can plot multiple views
on top of each other and
this can be useful for
example to annotate the chart.
To use it, we first nest
the specification under
the layer keyword.
And then we can add
another view or
a second specification
to this list of use.
And now the layer can show
the mean precipitation
with the rule mark.
And note that in this case here,
we only specify the y
location of this rule mark.
So that we get
an overall average for
the whole year,
not broken down by month.
And Vega-Lite automatically
makes the two layers share the x
and y-axis.
In this case,
only the y-axis and
the rule spans the full
width of the chart.
And this is an example of this
kind of reasoning that goes on
behind the scenes
in the compiler.
Another operator is the concat.
And we can use it
to a single few,
like the histogram we
had at the beginning and
visually concatenated
with another view.
In Vega-Lite, you invoke this
by just repping multiple single
view specifications
in an array and
then nest them under
the concat keyword.
Here we have the vconcat which
is for vertical concatenation.
We also have hconcat for
horizontal concatenation.
And the recurring design pattern
that we identified in these
concatenated views is that
we often have the same
specification.
Where just the field
is different.
Like in this case here, the only
thing that changed is whether
there's precipitation or
temperature on the y axis here.
And because this is such a
common operation, we promoted it
to it's own operator, and
we call this, The Repeat.
To use it, we start with a
specification of a single view,
and then nest the specification
and add some parameters.
First, we specify the list of
fields that we want to repeat
over or that we're
going create views for.
And then we replace
the fields name with
a reference to that
repeated data.
And so now we create one chart
for precipitation, one chart for
the temperature, and
one chart for the wind.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yes.
>> Did you change
the aggregate search?
>> Not right now.
>> Okay.
>> But
that's something [INAUDIBLE],
right now we only [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE] Keyword
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, here it's a keyword
because [INAUDIBLE] inside into
a column.
If you call it row, it lays out
in a row, and we can actually
take this a step further and
do both at the same time.
And this lets us
create a view for
each entry in the cross-product
of these two lists.
And so that's why we
can create this chart,
which is scattered plot matrix,
or SPLOM for short.
Of course, you could repeat
arbitrary views, but
here was a scatter plot.
And these SPLOMS are very useful
to investigate relationship
between multiple
quantity of variables.
And those can be, for
example [INAUDIBLE]-
>> A lot of the times you see
histograms for
those diagonal lines.
Is there a way to do
that in this, or-
>> You would have to do
concatenation in that case.
Yeah, so you can use these
SPLOMs as part of a dashboard.
And some of them may even
be composed in a dashboard.
So as I said, a dashboard
can have multiple views.
And they can be quite useful to
make sense of larger amounts
of data and
the relationships between them.
However, when you create
these dashboards,
you could of course
create them in Vega-Lite.
If you create every
view separately,
we would have to manually reason
about the data management and
how these charts fit together,
or how they're laid out.
And this is where the grammar
aspect of composition comes
into play.
And to illustrate this,
let's dissect this dashboard
that you see on the left.
So first,
we have a bunch of single views.
We have the histogram with
the different colored bursts and
a scatter plot and a bar chart.
A word histogram and the average
line and then what we do is
we can use the facet, repeat and
layer to live in modern space,
combine or annotate them
into these composed views.
The cool thing is in Vega Lite,
we can actually recombine
these composed views again
using the four basic operators.
So for instance,
we can take the three-layered
views on the right, and
create them in a data driven
way by repeating a layer.
But this hierarchical
composition that's going on here
can continue.
So we can combine the repeat
the two repeated views within
horizontally concatenation and
then vertically
concatenate that with the
[INAUDIBLE] view on the bottom.
>> Maybe I'm stuck, what's the
difference between [INAUDIBLE].
>> Facet is you define an
ordinal field that you partition
the data by, and repeat is
just repeat the same view and
every view gets access
to the full data.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So when we have this facet
down here, every view is for
each web type.
Okay, I understand
your confusion
here because they
are very similar.
You can think of it-
>> One is logically horizontal,
one is logically vertical.
>> Yeah, one is vertical,
one is horizontal.
So if you could
transpose the data,
you could use one operator.
Here we have two because
sometimes data just has
a particular format.
Okay, so oops.
So we created this whole view
with a single specification.
And because of this declarative,
Vega-Lite can actually optimize
the underlying data flow that's
below this visualization.
And in Vega-Lite, then the JSON
format, this hierarchical
composition is expressed
as you would expect it.
You can use an [INAUDIBLE]
specification in place of any
single view specification.
Vega-Lite and automatically
reasons about the data
management, and how scales and
axes should be combined.
And these efforts
are a powerful way to look
at multidimensional data.
However, to really interrogate
the data further you want to
interact with linked views and
then cover hidden relationships.
And let me show you how
to do that in Vega-Lite.
And this is where
the interaction part comes in.
So the basic building block for
our grammar of interactions
are these selections, and they
are the core building blocks.
Every selection defines
three components.
First, it is the event
processing, or how points that
are in the selection are chosen
interactively, for example,
whether it should happen
on a click or a hover.
Then the second thing is
the points of interest which
might be the data [INAUDIBLE] or
the visual elements.
And then lastly, a predicate
function to determine if a point
lies within this selection or
not Let's make these selections
a little bit more concrete.
Let's star with a simple
unit specification that
shows a scatterplot for cars.
So here the horsepower is on x,
the miles per gallon on y, and
the points are colored by
their manufacturing origin.
The simplest definition of the
selection consists of a name,
here, it's called picked,
and a type.
And then we can use some
conditional logic to change
the color of the points
based on what is clicked on.
So how’s this working?
The selection type is driving a
lot the default values here for
the selection.
So the three components that I
described earlier they are all
here but
of them are in the defaults.
So in particular this
single selection here
is saying unclick.
Select a single point,
not on hover.
And so, yeah,
when you click them,
they get added to the selection.
We can change the type
of the selection so
that we can add
multiple points to it.
Now the default says, on the
first click select the point.
And with Shift click,
we can toggle points in and
out of the selection.
And like with encodings,
we can override these defaults.
So for example, we can do,
instead of unclick,
we can do it on mouse hover.
And now we get this kind
of brushing effect here.
Okay, so besides the selections,
we also introduced
selection transforms, and
they're analogous to
the data transformations.
They're a way to manipulate what
it means to be in a selection.
So let me show you
how these work.
Here is the single view
specification from earlier.
And as a data analyst, we might
have a question of how does
the number of cylinders of
a car has to play into a trend
that we're seeing here
between horsepower and
[INAUDIBLE] kind of
negative correlation.
And so to look at that,
we can use the selection
and add a projection transform.
And this allows us to limit
the selection to one field
of the data.
So now, when we’re clicking
a particular point,
all the points that have
the same number of cylinders
are highlighted as well.
And with this interaction, I’m
able to see that there’s kind
of three groups of cylinders,
that’s eight at the bottom,
six at the mid-range,
and four at the top.
But to sort of direct
manipulation by clicking doesn't
really give me a sense of how
exhausted I'm looking at these
points.
So they maybe, I don't know,
maybe cards were like
25 all this and I wouldn't even
be able to see them unless I,
supposedly, click on them.
So besides this sort of
direct manipulation,
we can invoke a transform and
add some
dynamic query widgets to the
interactions that we've added.
And now [INAUDIBLE].
So now, we're binding
this to an input element.
And I can do the same clicking
and interaction in this chart
above, but we can also move
the slider back and forth and
see that there's cars with
three and five cylinders.
But only very few are with
three cylinders, so
it's kind of hard to click on
them if you're just using this.
And because Vega-Lite is
a declarative specification,
where all the defaults get
filled in automatically,
it's very easy to make small
changes and rapidly generate and
evaluate hypotheses
over this data.
>> Question?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you're showing
now introduction of
some UI controls.
Is there any support for
theming?
And I can image getting this
visualization into a larger
application, and then wanting
to have those controls look like
the other elements of
control in that application.
>> So here, these
are the standard HTML elements.
This is just a standard
range [CROSSTALK].
Okay, so here in this example,
I've edit just a few more
lines of additional codes so
that we can look an addition
to just the effect of
the number of cylinders,
also, what the effect of year
is on this, so now we have two.
And so perhaps luckily for
us, we can see that as we're
scrubbing on the year, that if
we're going forward in time cars
are becoming more efficient.
The timelines are moving
up the scalar plot if we're
moving forward in time here.
Okay, but all of these
selections transformations and
the selections are part of
a grammar of interaction.
And there's no templates or
so whatsoever.
And so, these are reusable
across a variety of different
selection types,
all of these components.
So here, for example, is a
continuous region selection, and
it's called an interval.
And now, by default, it allows
me to select a region in
both the x and the y dimension,
and so it can create this brush.
But I can go ahead and use this
transform to restrict it to
a single dimension here, just
the dimension that's used for x.
And now,
we have a brush that can only
be moved over horsepower.
And then we can also use a bind
transform to bind the selection
to the scale function,
rather than input element.
And so, any guess what
happens if we do that?
Binding selection to scale,
well this is what happens.
We can now start to pan and
zoom in the scatter plot, and
this might feel
a little bit magical.
But let me unpack what's
happening under the hood here.
What's happening is that we're
establishing a two way binding
between the selection and
the scales.
So the selection is populated
by the scale domains, and then
the scale domains themselves are
being driven by the selection.
And so this is what gives us
this panning and zooming.
So yeah,
there's this two-way binding and
then this reverse population.
And as you can see, there's
implicitly, Vega-Lite creates
this binding here, but you
don't have to manually do this.
But you could, of course,
override it or
put it into different
parts of a specification.
So all the interactions
I have shown you so
far have been restricted
to one single view.
But the reason why we designed
multi-view operators and
the grammar of
interaction is because
these interaction techniques
are most effective when we're
coordinating multiple
distinct visualizations.
And so I can use a repeat
operator to go from a single
scatter plot,
like the one I was using before,
to a matrix of scatter plots.
And now we can start brushing
and linking between all of them.
And automatically,
all of the selections work and
these force are views.
And with these sorts
of selections and
transformations, a whole number
of other custom techniques fall
out very naturally.
I can set out an Overview+Detail
for Focus+Context interaction.
Let me show you what
this might look like.
So we start just an area chart.
We have the same area,
try it again,
just with slightly taller.
And then, we're adding a,
we can add a selection to the
upper chart, and this case, it's
an interval selection restricted
to x, so we get the brush.
And then we can use that
same selection to change
the scale domain of
the second chart.
And then we get
this overview and
detail, brooks and
[INAUDIBLE] entex visualization.
This is similar to the other
example where I said
some magic happened.
Here, in this case, we split
where the selection is used and
where the selection is defined
into two separate views.
>> Is the word region your key
word or is it arbitrary text?
>> It's arbitrary text.
This is the name
of your selection.
You can define multiple
selections here,
if you wanted to.
Okay, so as a final example
of what we can do with this
interaction in the gram
of interactions,
let me walk through,
walk you through how to create
a variant of cross filtering.
Cross filtering, of course,
being a very popular
visualization technique.
So we will start with
a histogram, and
in this case it's flight data.
So this is a histogram that
shows us for the binned hour,
how many flights are taking
off at that time.
Then we might repeat the same
charts to look at different
variables, so besides hour,
also the delay and the distance,
how far the flight was.
So we just replace the field
with the reference to
the column.
And now, what we want to do
is have this at some kind of
layered interaction here.
So first we add a second layer,
which is just the same as above.
But we changed the color
to be this kind of gold.
And now we have two times
the same charts on top of
each other.
So let me just focus a little
bit and collapse this down.
So now we can add
a selection to the chart,
which is against just
restricted to x.
So we have the brush and we can
start brushing in these charts,
but nothing happens so far.
But we can use the selection
then to filter the data in
the other chart,
in the one with the golden bars.
And so now, What we get
is this cross filtering
interaction where the golden
bars in the other
charts correspond to the data
that is selected by the brush.
And this is all you need to
get cross filtering
working in Vega-Lite.
The cool thing is, what we're
talking about here is 35 lines
of JSON in a very
composable manner.
So we might be able to just
extend this to add another chart
that we can interact with.
Okay, so now that you've
seen our language design and
kinda what thoughts went into
the creation of this grammar of
interactive graphics.
Now we'll show you how
you can use Vega-Lite and
what we've built on top of it.
>> Cool, so first, let's see
how you can use Vega-Lite as
a programming tool kit.
So to use Vega-Lite we
provide a compiler that
translates a Vega-Lite
specification into a low level
specification that we
also developed at UDAP.
You can then use
Vega's run time and
create a visualization
both natively on the web.
Or via a server and
Windows visualization using
either Canvas or SVG.
And because we use the
underlying Vega architecture,
we also support our
streaming data as well.
And by using a declarative
JSON syntax we can still
a file format for altering and
sharing visualization.
And provide buying support for
different languages.
For example to perform
analysis in Python,
you can use a library
called Altair,
which is developed by Brian
Granger and Jake VanderPlas.
With Altair we can create
a histogram that we have
built earlier in Vega-Lite
using a native Python API,
that map there leads to
our visualizing text.
This can be convenient if you
perform the analysis in Python.
And we would like to also
highlight that Altair's API
is automatically generated
from Vega-Lite JSON schema.
This mean that when we publish
minor version, the Altair team
mostly need to just that
script to update their API.
And this approach not
native to just Python,
there are other projects that
try to wrap Vega-Lite and
other languages as well.
In a recent article
by Dan Saber,
which compared different Python
data visualization libraries,
Dan concludes that it's the
1:1:1 mapping between thinking,
code and visualization that's
his favorite thing about Altair.
And of course, the underlying
Vega-Lite language design.
And the Altair team themselves
also very excited about
our design.
And mention that they
say Vega and Vega-Lite,
perhaps the best
existing candidates for
a principled lingua franca
of data visualization.
And just a few weeks ago,
we're excited that JupyterLab,
which is the next
generation of the popular
Jupyter Notebook Wood chips
weigh in Vega-Lite by default.
In addition to use Vega-Lite
directly and via wrapper APIs,
Vega-Lite can also enable
higher level tools.
Like graphical user interface
applications that can let user
create Vega-Lite plots via UI,
without writing code directly.
And we can even use Vega-Lite
as a representation for
visualization recommendation.
To give an example of a tool
that does both of these,
we'd like to show you Voyager
visualization to augment manual
visualization specification
with recommendation.
And the goal for these two is
to promote better it's for
the analysis and [INAUDIBLE] for
meta analysis [INAUDIBLE].
And to the part this goal,
we should use Vega-Lite to
[INAUDIBLE] specify and
use Vega-Lite as a model
to recommend visualizaiton.
Here's the virtual interface,
and
here we are showing
a dataset about cards.
And Voyager is a single unified
tool that allow user to
with decision and also show
recommendation to user.
After loading the dataset
without having to create any
views manually.
We first show univariate
summaries, so
that users can browse
different chart.
And say that let's
see a summary of different
data fields for example.
Here you can see that in this
data set a lot of cars have
an even number of cylinders.
And at least some type of car
have odd number of cylinders.
You can also see that this
data set is quite old,
it's from 1970 to 80 something,
older than me at least.
[LAUGH] And, you can also use
a drag and drop interface
to be your specific view
similar to Tableau.
For example, dragging
Horsepower to the x shelf would
create a visualization
that shows of Horsepower.
And under the field, we'll just
create Vega-Lite specification
that map Horsepower
to the external, and
use Vega-Lite to render
the visualization.
Based on this specified view,
we'll just also suggest
different time related views to
help analysts convert
into variables.
And alternative ways to
summarize or encode the data.
For example,
up here we recommend
the related summary views.
And to do so, once you consider
the Vega-Lite classification
of the data above.
And determine if you can
calculate summary views by
applying aggregation of binning.
And here, we see a part that
shows a histogram of horsepower
and a plot that shows
mean of horsepower.
You can similarly suggest
other kinds of plot sets.
For example, suggesting a plot
that shows horsepower with other
additional variable, like
horsepower and acceleration,
horsepower and displacement,
or horsepower and.
And to give user more control
to create a collection of
views manually, provide
a wildcard to specify wiring
properties of
the visualization collection.
For example, on the left
we have wildcards for
wiring multiple fields.
If I drag a quantitative
fields y bar to y,
we can create a gallery of
scatter plots showing horsepower
with other quantitative
variables.
Under the hood,
we also use Vega-Lite for
[INAUDIBLE] use a wildcard.
And in this case, for a
wildcard, we basically enumerate
different qualitative fields for
the y channel.
With all these different
interactions, data plots.
And this can rapidly
explore different aspect of
the data set, and
create specific visualizations
to address that specific goals.
And to cap again, whenever you
serve specified things manually,
Voyager creates a Vega-Lite
specification and
renders the plot.
And also analyze the Intend
the user provide from the visual
interface, and provide it
with fully recommendation.
For more details about different
kind of recommendation and
specifications, as we'll ask
the underlying curly language,
that we view on top
of what I call home.
You can look at our research
paper, and I was so
happy to come to give another
talk about Voyager in detail,
if you're interested.
So from Voyager, we have see
that Vega-Lite can be used to
support recommendations of
data and visual encodings.
One area of visual work that
we are excited about is,
applying similar approach to
recommended interactions.
We legalize concise in tasks
to composing interaction.
We can just add one small
more target that changes
to a specification, and
generate atomically different
interaction technique.
With these small changes,
we can easily write a program to
enumerate this space of
interaction design, for
visualization and recommend
interaction techniques as well.
To summarize in this talk,
we have shown you
the design of Vega-Lite,
which include building blocks
for specifying single views.
And compose them into
interactive multi-view graphics.
We have also shown that
Vega-Lite can be used directly
as a programming tool,
but very and
on the web and
we are other wrappers such as.
In addition, Vega-Lite can
enable graphical user interface,
as well as recommendation
in a system like Voyager.
And we are happy to
announce that last Tuesday,
we released the first production
version of Vega-Lite 2,
which improved all
the composition and
interaction features we
described in this talk.
And we also have tutorials, and
documentations on line at
vega.github.io/vega-lite.
And if you're interested, you
can start paying with Vega-Lite,
using our online editor, without
the need to install anything,
we also provide auto completion,
and some hints for
documentation on the editor.
And finally, we'd like to thank
contributors to Vega-Lite, and
related projects.
Of course,
not just to us or Jeff and
who coauthored the paper and
this project.
Many people contribute to
Vega-Lite, Altair and Voyager.
And yeah, so,
here are the top contributors.
And with that, we're happy
to take questions, and
we also can demo the [INAUDIBLE]
editor if you want to.
>> [APPLAUSE]
I wonder what is the computation
engine under especially
dealing with big data?
So do you support some kind
of sampling to be able to
quickly to produce
some visualization, or
some iterative approach to
defining the visualization?
>> We don't do that inside
Vega and Vega-Lite directly.
But, because there are many
ways to buy data to Vega-Lite.
You can use URL, or you can buy
data at one time, which means
that the applications that you
write can do some sampling
before they pass the data
to Vega, or Vega-Lite.
>> And I think one of the next
steps for us is also,
working on, or taking to
declare if it's specifications,
and reasons more about
what is happening exactly.
I think now that we have not
just the visualization, but
also all the interactions
in declare to play.
We can actually reason
about where data has to be,
and what data we have to update
when users start interacting
with the chart.
So we think this can be
a step to really have
interactive applications
of a large data,
which also actually happens to
be kind of my research area.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and for
applications like Azure where
multiple Vega-Lite pots
are displayed, the fact that
Vega-Lite is declarative,
one thing that we are planning
to do is trying to analyze
common data source for
different pots,
and reduce the redundancy when
you calculate application, and
all the transform for
different [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, the other thing is just
using aggregation, and actually
Daniel and I worked this summer
on different aggregation
techniques for vegalization,
and we actually used Vega and
Vega-Lite for
the rendering part of it.
>> One more question.
So the idea of vegalization
is actually very fascinating.
And I wonder, is it possible
to get to the extreme end,
where you can pretty much
create any kind of grammar,
just by interacting
on the canvas,
without any kind of
>> So that's more about the,
how you would create these
kinds of visualizations?
Or the specification of? Yeah.
>> One of the reasons that we
big to develop application like.
So by having a model that
can use as a representation,
then you can do any kind of UI,
you can do other UI, that do
things seem not to [INAUDIBLE]
but, while indifferent,
they are maybe on tablet or
whatever, so the answer is yes,
but we obviously have to spend
time to deal out the UI.
>> One example is the LIRA tool,
okay,
which is a tool that
Arvin developed.
>> Which lets you,
with a drag and drop interface,
create data specifications.
And he's now
a faculty at MIT and wants-
>> He will be in-
>> He will be in Fall.
He's looking at, [CROSSTALK]
>> What is the name
of the program?
>> LIRA
>> Yeah.
>> Wasn't LIRA
originally developed on
top of D3 and then later-
>> It's on Vega one.
>> Then Arvin invented Vega two,
which Vega-Lite
one was based on.
Now Vega-Lite two is out.
Which is based on Vega 3, and
actually I have not started
updating LIRA to also use some
of the automatic recommendations
of the smart defaults from
Vega Lite, so the new version of
LIRA is actually using Vega Lite
>> And Vega.
>> And Vega, but what Arvin is
interested in is looking at how
you can create interactions,
by demonstrating them in the UI.
This was a lot of things.
[LAUGH]
>> Mm-hm, yes?
>> When you're developing
a language like Vega-Lite,
you picked a couple of core
operations that you fasted and
repeat, and that's what
thing is, a couple of
fundamental market types, the
bar to the right and the circle.
How secure are you that
you got them all, for
some definition of them all, or
ultimately is there a shape
to the space that you've got,
or is it that you had a handful
of demos and you decided you'd
build a language that was good
enough to hit all those demos?
>> That's a great question.
We're not claiming that we for
things like Vega-Lite,
which we aim more for
our sense in chromographics.
So we've done support like
bubble pack layout, for example.
And probably we're
in support of that.
At the Vega level, which is
an attitude that's lower level
often perfect those
kind of things.
So yeah, we don't claim
to support all that.
Why we try to do is,
try to aim for
lot's more frequently
used things so.
>> The story behind
Vega-Lite is that,
the first version was actually
created to build Voyager One,
that was the original reason why
we even wanted this language.
And then, it was a paragraph
in the paper, and
then we knew this is actually
something that can be useful
beyond just Voyager One, so
we made it it's own library, and
added interactions and
compositions and
all these things
>> Yeah, feature requests, and
even better full requests
all the time, too.
>> So,
ggplot tends to be used for,
a lot of people using
art to generate, and
visualizations that you can
incorporate into papers.
That means they've got styling
and a couple other things.
Sort of a little bit easier than
actually manipulating CSS in
this [INAUDIBLE]
>> Is that something that you
guys are gonna look at,
or have something?
Part of this is sort of,
once you've got this,
how much can people
sort of add to it?
>> Yeah, we actually
already have that in Vega.
Vega has different renderers,
not just to SVG, but
also to Canvas.
And that's why normal
CSS rules don't apply.
But what you can do is, you can
apply or, you can set this,
what did they call that styles?
>> Config.
>> Yeah, in the config, you can
define how certain elements
should be, what the default
color should be,
what the margin should be,
and so.
>> So the answer is,
there are ways to allow
Vega to customize plot.
Even though what we show
in the talk is mostly
the concise syntax.
Most of the things in
Vega-Lite can be customizable.
And even for
things that you cannot customize
directly in Vega-Lite,
because we compile things into
lower level Vega [INAUDIBLE].
If you find a rare use case that
we haven't invented in Vega-Lite
yet, you can use the variable
output and customize them too.
And we also have gaming systems
to enforce that all the axis
are the bomber should have those
in color for this kind of thing.
You can create a theme using
Vega-Lite, and Vega as well.
>> How many other people
do renders for Vega?
Is it just you guys?
>> So
there were some people who built
a prototype for, what, GL?
And then map D uses figure
as their format, between
the front and back end, and
they are thinking about
also building a renders.
>> I think the biggest
one that made someone to
do would be [INAUDIBLE],
but for normal,
you say we don't have that big
data [INAUDIBLE] like cover.
>> That's, yeah.
I think that's one really
exciting part about Vega and
Vega-Lite.
It's just this
ecosystem of tools.
And having one specification
language that different tools
can generate.
And then different tools that
can interpret this language, or
reasonable different
parts of that language,
automatically optimize parts,
render it with different tools.
You can go from
Vega-Lite to Vega,
if you need the customization,
as Han mentioned.
You can then use Vega and
Vega-Lite more or less,
as data exchange formats.
Which is one of the core
design principles behind Vega.
>> And we know that,
for example,
Wikipedia all ready supports
Vega, because the fact that
it's declarative, so
we can easily add it to Wiki.
And now that they released
Vega-Lite 2, they are interested
in having Vega-Lite,
as part of Wikipedia as well.
>> For them, it was crucial that
it wasn't general JavaScript,
because they don't want people
to run opportunity JavaScript
[LAUGH] at other people's
computers, for obvious reasons.
And so their declarative
form was the perfect,
apparent way to express this.
And we also hope that this could
be applied to other things like
publications maybe, where
instead of you having to embed
a figure that's just an image,
it could be
an interactive visualization,
which comes with your paper.
>> Yeah, and we do use data for
papers too, so yeah.
>> Unfortunately they're not
interactive in the PDF anymore.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So is there an extensibility
model for the language, and
how is the language defined?
Because it's just
all these questions.
[LAUGH]
>> So
the language is defined by
having a save of primitive, and
just primitive interact
with each other.
So in that way, adding things
is, when we add new things,
we have to be a little careful,
because it's not just like add
one thing that stand alone.
If you wanna add a new D3
library, you can just anything,
because your user for D3 would
wire things up manually, but
for Vega-Lite,
because this would automatically
interact with other things.
Then, it needs some casual
configuration when you
add things.
For extensible part,
one thing that we are adding is
having ability to have macro.
Like for example, if you think
about graphic like box plot.
Box plot basically
have the box part,
which is basically a rectangle,
then you have the line.
So having the ability to add
macro for even more concise
syntax, is one thing that
we all ready have support.
>> Maybe if your question
was specifically about how
the language is defined?
So right now, it is defined
by what we write down in our
documentation, and
by the implementation.
But we actually also generate a
JSON schema, which sets exactly
what our allowed properties for
the Limewire.
So they [INAUDIBLE] but
they are obvious only syntax,
to much semantics of things.
>> Yes, far for [INAUDIBLE]
denied you stop playing
[INAUDIBLE] online, then if you
type something that's invalid,
they'll warn and [INAUDIBLE] it.
>> Yeah.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So [INAUDIBLE] scenario,
animation components to, so
do people do animations
with visualizations?
>> So right now,
for both Vega 3 and
Vega-Lite don't have animation
inside our language.
But what you can do is,
if you use SVG,
you can already apply CSS
animations all ready.
We do plan to add animations
first to Vega 3, and
then later to Vega-Lite, but
not in the next few months.
>> In general, what can you
media space of grammar for
emissions not necessary with
data visualizations, but
general grammar for emissions
of our content emissions?
>> I don't know if
that's we specific for.
But for the clarity of
the animation, like for
example D3 sort of tried to
Embed animation transition
into domain specific language.
Since this transition is sort
of similar in a way, so yeah,
I guess those are the two
that I know of.
And as it CSS transition can be
applied to really, I thought as
well, if you us SVG, and when
you say, for example when you
have a streaming data, and
you keep updating a tone, and
you want to transition the part,
then you can do this transition.
>> But there will also
be interesting to,
again, reason about
the specification,
and having some kind of
grand aspect to animations.
So that, an animation is by
default, somehow meaningful.
But I think that requires some
more thinking to actually make
it fully work.
>> I was gonna add on to
that first question a little
bit more.
Is that, if you were to drop
this into a server client model,
where the server is
doing the computation,
how would you break up data,
cuz you have specification.
But you wanna break it out so
that somehow it generates not
biased at all by Power BI.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Generates some sort of data
view that it wants, gets it
back, then does this thing.
How would you kind of
handle that at [INAUDIBLE]?
>> So Vega is fully reactive.
It's a fully reactive system.
There is an API for
adding data to it, updating or
moving tuples from the data.
And then it automatically
only updates the parts of
the visualization that
need to be updated.
But if you are taking your
Vega-Lite specification,
generating the Vega from it,
it kinds of expects that
all the data is there.
So if you want to push some
of the computation down,
you would have to split
up that data flow, and
have some part on the server,
some part on the client.
So that's a lot of
interactive parts.
>> Yeah, I guess the obvious
next question's like,
database if you're like me.
Is there a common data format
that I can compile my request
into, that any kind of
backend server could manage,
and then piggyback that
data if you wanted?
>> Are you talking with
purely about static?
Visualizations now?
>> Cause if you
have interactive,
if you have interactive
visualizations,
then an interaction
could effect something,
some part of the data, right?
And then you would
have to rerun the query
on interaction and update it.
I actually wrote
a paper about this,
which I guess I should say.
[LAUGH].
>> Was that at the workshop?
>> At the DSA workshop.
>> Yeah.
>> 2015, 14, 14?
>> Okay, never mind,
you guys specifically
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, so
they're in that area where we
talked about this idea of taking
into specification and
the reason about the data flow
behind it, and
augmenting to split it up, and
dynamically change where certain
operations are taking place.
But that was before we even
had a declarative form of
interactions and visualizations.
Now we have that, so I think
now we can actually go and
get to that vision and do what
you and I want to do [LAUGH].
>> So basically, to try to
answer your question a little
bit more, given a [INAUDIBLE]
you can write program
that can decouples just
the data for a part.
And then you can execute
that part on sober.
But the tricky part will come
when you have interaction.
So you should only decouple
the part that doesn't involve
instruction, otherwise,
it's going to be a lot
of code involved.
But just, if you I want to
exactly transform part that do
before you do instruction, you
can extract that to the server.
And for Vega,
there's a data flow API that
you can run the data flow of
Vega without caring about
visual encoding at all.
>> Or it can be a bit more
nuanced something in between
those two approaches where you
send some data to the client
that allows for some limited
set of interactions.
For example, for
the cross filtering,
you could send the data
cube to the client.
But probably not the whole data
cube because it's too large, so
maybe you restrict it to certain
dimensions of the data cube.
Yeah, are there
questions around that?
>> In [INAUDIBLE] you showed the
wildcards is that Vega reasoning
and doing its own tech discovery
or is there some expectation
that there's some scheme
associated with the data set?
>> Yeah, so some [INAUDIBLE]
then we, given the input data,
we will analyze the schema, and
allow [INAUDIBLE] the schema.
And the question mark one hard
thing is actually a part of
another language, that we
built on top of Vega-Lite,
we don't have time to
demonstrate much about it.
But basically, so
that's Vega at the lower level,
that's Vega-Lite that
[INAUDIBLE] to Vega.
Both Vega and Vega-Lite describe
a single visualization,
but then that's another
level of language,
[INAUDIBLE] collection
of visualization, and
allow you to sort of group
things and sort things based on
ranking like perceptual
effectiveness ranking.
So [INAUDIBLE] at the level
on top of Vega-Lite.
>> Right, or in Alec's terms.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> So, it was designed for
Voyager, but you can use it
to the other applications.
>> Are you thinking of releasing
that as a stand-alone thing or
is each kind of a [INAUDIBLE]
to Voyager right now?
>> The thing is
called [INAUDIBLE].
I know a few colleagues in
research that try to use it for
other purpose already.
For example, I don't know if
you know about the work by?
He does reverse
engineering visualization.
And to train his
machine learning model,
he use compass to generate
a bunch of examples that
he knows was formed to, so that
he can have a lot of training
example to get basically like
an OCR for visualization.
So that's one application,
I know that another friend at
Georgia Tech tried to apply
the same engine more for
like national language UI for
visualization.
>> It's sort of a protein
synthesis system in
Alex's terms, right?
You have a partial program,
partial specification, and
then there's a system
that fills in those holes
to create these more detailed
full Vega-Lite specifications,
which then get compiled to Vega.
>> So if there aren't
any other questions,
I encourage you to come up and
maybe you can make some time to
be with these folks [INAUDIBLE].
And let's thank our speakers.
>> [APPLAUSE]